Iranian authorities say the crew of a
Ukrainian airliner that crashed in
Tehran never called for help according
to an early crash report officials say
the plane was trying to turn back when
it went down leaving a trail of debris
in a field on the outskirts of the city
but a series of holes like this one in a
wing are leading some to question the
idea that the plane had mechanical
difficulties Kris Van Cleave is
following all of this for us Chris good
morning those holes certainly raise a
lot of questions don't they well good
morning there are a lot of questions and
one of the real challenges here is
Iranian government statements have to be
treated with skepticism we do know a
team of Ukrainian investigators are now
on the ground in Iran they say they are
looking for any evidence something like
a missile or anti-aircraft fire struck
flight 752 this morning we know very
little and answers may not come quickly
but it does appear the plane was on fire
as it came down our hearts go out to all
the families mourners gathered in
Edmonton last night to remember the 63
Canadian victims on Ukraine
International Airlines flight 752 after
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau vowed to
find out what happened Canadians will be
asking for answers and we're there to
support and find out the truth
the plane was only in the air for a few
minutes before disaster struck the
Boeing 737s flight data was abruptly
silenced as it climbed towards 8,000
feet during a seemingly normal take-off
the flight happening just hours after
Iran fired rockets into Iraq Canadian
Transport Minister Marc Garneau we lost
contact with it suggesting that
something very unusual happened holes in
some wreckage at the crash site drew
comparisons to damage done to the
Malaysian air flight that was shot out
of the sky over Ukraine more than five
years ago and you say categorically one
way or another that the plane was not
shot down I cannot it is too early to
speculate the Iranians say they
recovered the black boxes but they were
damaged and may be missing some data the
country says it won't give the u.s. or
Boeing access former NTSB chairman James
Hall UK squash speculation except with
the truth and the only way you're going
to have the truth here
is have a thorough and fair
investigation the 176 on board the
three-and-a-half-year-old airliner
included a newlywed couple several
children and students returning to
universities after winter break among
them PhD student gana Mott as dari
professors described her as an
exceptional student and an environmental
leader just the thought of one of our
students are dying in such a tragic
circumstances it's just horrifying
this is 737 but it was not one of the
grounded max airplanes it has an
excellent safety history now this
particular aircraft went through a
maintenance check just days before the
crash the airline has a solid safety and
maintenance record the Iranians are
running this investigation
which comes during very tense times
between Iran and the West and that could
be another challenge Anthony all right
Chris thank you
you